here in los angeles and all around the
country kids
are gradually returning to school you
know
my daughter's uh back in school now and
i think my son she's going back
soon yeah yeah and and your kids going
back yeah yeah
my daughter is going back next week i
think yeah yeah my daughter's back in
school now and then my son's i think
going to go back
uh to military academy where i'm sending
him
to be tough he doesn't know yet what's
that he doesn't know oh god no
yeah yeah i don't want him to know until
he wakes up there at west point
at six o'clock in the morning get up
give us 30 push-ups what's happening
no it's uh it's a big deal kids are
going back to school it's going to be a
massive transition
and i really appreciated this public
service announcement
the department of education just
released aimed at helping kids and their
parents
adjust to all this new time apart
with covet infections down many
districts are finally reopening schools
this means your children will once again
experience the joy of in-person classes
with their peers
but it's also a big change for parents
for the last year
you've spent every waking moment of
every day with your children
and now they'll be gone for several
hours each day
you may find it difficult to fill the
childless hours of your day
don't worry that's normal try activities
to keep you busy
like completing a jigsaw puzzle or
painting your bedroom something fun you
can do together
you may even want to spend some time in
your children's room to feel closer to
them while they're away
or even hop in the car and take care of
some errands
the important thing is to use this new
free time to rest
relax and reflect on the joy of children
in your lives
this message brought to you by the
department of education
[Music]
i didn't know having sex could look like
that
is that sex not the way i've
experienced it yeah it seems to be
lasting a long time right right
and there's two people there's two
people
i don't know well wonders never cease